ce théâtre pour enfants de le vivez
maintenant un dortoir pour les personnes
déplacées il y avait là d' d'un un coup
de main
tous deux originaires de marioupol ils
sont sans nouvelles de leur famille
depuis quatre jours moi je suis venu
crier j'ai cerné nous ne savons pas
s'ils ont de la nourriture de l'eau de
l'électricité ni même s'ils sont en vie
c'est vraiment terrible de voir la photo
d'un soldat russe mort et de s'en
réjouir mais oui nous nous réjouissons
quand ils tuent des soldats russes et ce
sera comme ça jusqu'à ce qu'ils partent
en colonie c'est n'est pas l'outil dans
ce théâtre c'est comédien de profession
offre des conseils aux nouveaux
arrivants ils font aussi office de
gardien
à l'intérieur des femmes et des enfants
est enfoui d'autres régions de l'ukraine
il ignore ce que l'avenir leur réserve
comment pouvons-nous leur pardonner cela
non c'est impossible de pardonner bien
sûr que non jamais pour beaucoup les
crimes de l'union soviétique était déjà
une persécution des russes contre les
ukrainiens
leur arbre généalogique tous les
ukrainiens peuvent trouver l'histoire
d'un membre de leur famille qui a été
exécuté et ceux qui s'en souviennent
savent qu'il ne faut rien attendre de
bon choix parce qu'il ne change pas les
ukrainiens savent bien que très peu de
ruse protestent contre la guerre
nous ne pouvons pas pardonner aux russes
leur silence se taire c'est être
complice de cette agression
c'était le dimanche du pardon selon le
calendrier orthodoxe
mais pour le père landry des sept
églises la banlieue de le vivre le
pardon n'est pas prévu pour vladimir
poutine
c'est dans le livre du deutéronome
maudit soit celui qui viole le
territoire de son voisin
nous pourrions prier pour le peuple
russe en tant que peu perdu mais pas
pour ceux qui dirigent cette guerre non
dieu nous en garde
moins de deux semaines après le début de
l'invasion de l'ukraine par la russie il
est déjà clair que les liens entre ces
deux pays sont prisées pour des
générations